[Music]
okay
I know some of you guys are tired of the
intro music well if you are just listen
to it again
[Music]
sorry that's a little bit more tow
that's a little bit where tow and that's
Spanish for death because you die in
other countries too in Spain Portugal
Africa
everywhere you go you die brother and
that's the crazy part and I'm sorry to
start us off like that but that's not
what's happening right now right now we
are in the live category we're checking
that live box if somebody passed you a
note right now and it said do you live
yes or no you would check yes because
you're alive sorry I know some of you
guys it's it's a it's a sentence almost
so you have to deal with while some
people seem to just be able to embrace
it and just just be just just have joy
just jumping out of their dang skin you
know just like Joey is just rappelling
out of their armpits and just spelunking
out of their nose you know constantly
and some people have that natural joy
that's what I call that that natural joy
tnj not to be confused with TMJ which is
lock jaw and lock jaw is something you
could get it was rabies little brother
because I grew up you know a lot of
people know in the rabies built a lot of
rabies a lot of lice body bugs you know
we had one fella was always scratching
his neck and they would have to uh you
know put these almost make him like a
mummy because he was scratching his neck
so much because he got the body bugs and
people get different types of stuff you
know and that's one thing that he got
but TMJ was also it was I think
something like lockjaw where you
couldn't eat for a while it was like a
diet but one that you're basically your
central nervous system and forced a diet
on you and you couldn't open your mouth
and that was something I remember my
mother told me be careful out there
because you could get lockjaw and
especially around this time of year you
know I find that October do you realize
it's October do you realize you can eat
and II all month long and nobody will
judge you you could be at a Funeral and
break out a snicker you know a baby
snicker and nobody's gonna judge you
heavily because that's natural because
it's that time you know I mean you could
just you know you could crack open a
pixie stick and bust a couple rails
right up your snout you know like like
frickin like like Kokkola focus you know
like snort Allah focus bruh you could do
a couple grams of great Pixy powder and
nobody's heavily going to judge you and
that's because it's Halloween time and
Halloween I always feel as ah I mean
it's the best I mean you could dress up
like a [ __ ] ghost and go to Burger
King tomorrow and people will just think
that you know you're just trying to get
a head start on the year and we had a
girl in our neighborhood that would go
trick-or-treating year-round and some
people thought she was a mentally
challenged you know maybe had a little
speck of the Tisza moaner because I grew
up in the Tizen belt as well and that's
basically a lot of the South and Midwest
ISM is heavy heavy out there you note
ISM dips drips heavy it drips heavy in
the genetic caverns out there you know
it just drips off the ceiling and every
now and then a drop catches somebody and
they are they are you know they get
caught up their feelings and emotions
and the way that they live their life
gets caught up and that's autism and
everybody's got a little bit of it you
know and I don't I'm sure had a splash
hit me on the back you know when I was
going through the genetic caverns into
the universe and I got a touch
you know because I'll see a lot of times
autistic kids and they flare up kind of
when I come by a little you know it's
almost like if a dog hears something the
distance and I'm not referring autistic
children as animals or autistic humans
I'm not doing that at all but I'm saying
that they'll have that same you ever see
like a dog like if you are if
dog is far away and you make a sound in
the dog looks that's a lot of time what
happen with me when I get around people
that have mental disabilities because
they know that the thread in me is
recently removed from the quilt that
they're made of that I'm partisan that
I'm partisan or whatever they got and
I've always thought that I've always
felt a little bit on the people say on
the spectrum but I say on the I don't
want to say on the rainbow but I say on
the waterslide of autism because it's a
wild ride but happy October guys happy
October 1st I oh wait it's October 2nd
it's October 2nd I'm recording this on
October 1st I hope you had a good
weekend you know I hope you know people
got into the football we got some people
that called in about that about some of
the different kneeling a lot of the
unique perspectives on it and so we're
going to rifle through some of those in
a little bit we got we got our Amanda's
coming back in I know people hate him
some people love him so we're just gonna
figure out we got if we're going to try
it again a little bit of a flow we can
see how that goes and what else is going
on in my world I mean recently I've been
I'll give you a sensual update I am I'm
in seven days of no masturbation and for
me that's good and so I'm feeling pretty
hopeful about that one of my problems is
a lot of times once I tell people I'm
doing something I screw it up you know
like the second like you know I'll say
that to you guys and I'll get excited
I'll get caught up in my own hope and
then it just you know it's like a that
creates a bad recipe inside of me that
then somehow I end up you know you know
looking at masturbation or touching
myself and I don't want to be doing that
anymore I don't want to be touching
myself why because I'm an adult you know
and I've been touched trust me I've been
touched enough by myself I've given
myself enough easy access to my Weiner
and in my body and so I think it's time
sometimes to start
cage myself up from myself and have a
little bit more respect for my seed
what else do oh I'll watch it show last
chance you I don't know if you've seen
this but I used to work over in in
Mississippi I worked on a farm over
there for a couple of summers in a row
two three summers they are right on the
extra bet on the Louisiana Mississippi
border and this this show on Netflix
last chance you is about mostly
african-american black boys that play
football at a at a school called Eastern
Mississippi Community College and it
really kind of captures a little bit of
that slow vibe that goes on in a lot of
small towns if you get a chance but not
heavily recommend that it's a pretty
good show this past weekend yeah that
October I remember when I was young
doing Halloween was always a special
time you know I remember in high school
eating mushrooms
you know psychedelic mushrooms little
trip snacks brain Mentos basically
Mentos for your soul I mean you you pop
a couple I mean the first time we went
to get some mushrooms I went with some
kids who had already gotten them before
and so they were fired up and we went
there and I'd never seen as many
mushrooms in my entire life not even at
a grocery and we got literally we got
probably half of a black big black
garbage bag full of mushrooms and we
took them to a party and at the party
people ate him we went inside the party
people ate him and about an hour later
it was probably maybe 40 people at the
party
an hour later nobody was in the house
but everybody was still at the party
people were lost in the woods people
were trapped some people were trapped
behind the swimming pool even though
there was no way to get trapped behind
it because it was just a round pool
people were playing hide-and-go-seek
with themselves two kids were in the
bathroom and didn't know each other
was in the bathroom I mean people were I
mean you could just hear people's souls
just jerking off in the distance you
know it was like I mean it was just like
bison we're just roaming through
people's souls for the first time and
then Indians were showing up and hunting
them and that's what was going on you
could feel people shifting you could
feel people shifting gears mentally and
emotionally at the same time when people
were bent out on the mushrooms on that
Halloween and then now we had a lot of
mushrooms so those went on for a few
days and children were eating them and
they I remember dressing up like Where's
Waldo and I got an a powdered sugar
fight with a couple of people who I
didn't know which is fun at first but
anytime you're fighting with condom it's
fun at first violent at the end you know
what I'm saying crack open a packet of
mustard on somebody it's cute for about
40 seconds and then [ __ ] escalates you
know next thing you know you're trying
too [ __ ] hard chunks of relish in
people's tear ducts and [ __ ] and that's
when [ __ ] escalates but but I remember a
buddy of mine this kid Todd drank some
gasoline high on mushrooms he was jacked
up on something you know and he he
[ __ ] up at the service station
timesaver the service station bus used
to be called time saver because I guess
they assumed that if you stopped there
you were gonna save you a couple extra
seconds but old Todd he really earned
himself a couple of extra seconds in the
hospital days even from drinking the
gasoline but yeah I had good times on
Halloween I was Where's Waldo one time I
was peppermint pat another time I got
jacked up on on some type of uppers and
I was peppermint pat for Halloween and
it's really basically take some long
johns that are the pants and you take
the long johns shirts which is just kind
of the same material as the pants but
it's a shirt and you sew peppermints to
it just tie the peppermints you know all
over it get you a little hat a little
excuse me like a little beanie hat
hook a few peppermints on the vet and
suddenly you get a cane like a cane for
a grandparent and you paint it red and
white stripes and suddenly you [ __ ]
peppermint pat you know and and it's not
even a character but it is a character
and people like who are you and it's
like I'm peppermint patty you know what
I'm saying let me hide a little bit of
this mint up in that ass you film me let
me breath freshen that crotch you feel
me so that was another costume that I
had I remember this story man this is
the first time that I knew when I was
young my father lived with us and my
father was really old you know and so we
would go trick-or-treating and my mother
would take us my mother had worked all
day you know and so she got home and she
was a lot of time frustrated and my dad
would stay home excuse me I'm gonna have
to clear my throat a lot of times you
hear me clear my throat you hear me I
make that sound because I got a big lip
you know I got that I got that uh that
uh wood is it I got that that's all she
me that tuna sashimi for the bottom lip
and so a lot of water and a lot of
coagulates bunch up down there in the
bottom of my lip you know I'm kind of
bubblegum pinned down there and so you
know a lot of time water buildup right
there and I'd probably make a pearl if
you gave me enough time I'd probably
make a pearl in my mouth I bet when I
die if the last person who comes by my
body just pulls my lip down then I find
them a beautiful um yeah a beautiful you
know
geological treat right there and that's
gonna be a pearl because I got them
coagulates you know my mouth kind of
flows into this this place where there's
no way way for the water to escape so
anyway that's what I'm going on if you
hear me making sounds it's the sounds
I'm making because people sometime will
call in or email some guy emailed one
time I can't I can't listen to the
podcast anymore you know he's always
drinking your own spit that's what he
accused me of doing drink
own spit what are you talking about dude
like I'm liking like I'm an orphan in
the Sahara
what do you mean drinking moan spit dude
I got a I'm not gonna drown bro I'm not
gonna drown so you can have an easy Lea
listening atmosphere you know so every
time you hear me making that sound
no I'm surviving okay that I want to be
at other stages in my life you know I'm
not gonna have my brother be at my
funeral and say oh my brother drowned
out because he didn't want to swallow
his spit because he had shame about it
I'm sorry you know different people make
different sounds go put your ear up to
your stepmother I bet she sounds like a
piece of [ __ ] maybe some people stepmoms
a decent anyhow on word so I remember we
had Halloween and my father would stay
home and my father was old at that time
he was 76 years old maybe 75 and my
mother would take us trick-or-treating
and I didn't realize at that time yet
that my father was old I didn't I mean I
knew that he was like physically slower
but I guess I didn't realize uh I didn't
really realize how he saw me you know I
didn't realize how he envisioned me or
looked at me or if he did any
differently because of his age and I
remember when trick-or-treating with my
mom and my brother and I got in a fight
so we were we were Raggedy Ann and and
Andy and both of us we both started out
as Andy and then my brother beat my ass
enough for I kind of look more like a
Raggedy Ann and not you know just my I
painted gone out my hair was sprayed out
and my Raggedy Ann outfit was all busted
up looking more like a dress so at that
time you know I was showing up back at
my door like a real badge you film them
and so we get back to our house we going
trick-or-treating we had a pretty decent
time and wasn't my mother with the four
children my sister and a stroller
and we get back there and my brother and
I run up to the door and my father came
to the door and he looked at us and he
went he got the candy bowl and just said
you know take what you want you know and
that's when he didn't realize it was us
he didn't realize it was his own
children and that was like the first
moment that like I guess I realized that
maybe my dad just couldn't relate to me
that well even just because of his age
like he just didn't you know maybe dad's
forget I mean my dad had just seen me
you know an hour earlier when I left you
know my brother and I wearing our
costumes and stuff but I remember
getting back to the door and he didn't
know it was us and I just remember
feeling this this this disconnect
immediately this like this it wasn't
like a feeling of pain but it was just
feeling immediately where I understood
where where we were in relation to each
other like I knew immediately there was
this divide where he just didn't there
maybe like he could confuse me with
other kids that you know he didn't
remember things that well that there was
just this immediately there was this
element that and probably at that age
too that you know he didn't recognize me
you know there was probably a lot of
fear that set in like internally then
you know this feeling that you know
maybe he couldn't protect me or
something if he didn't know I was his
own there might have been some you know
nocturnal animal istic vibes going on
but but that was one moment that I
really shook me and I was like wow you
know you know my dad is is he's old you
know he doesn't know that my brother not
standing here you know who don't have
mass on who have you know like headbands
that have like yarn and stuff and are
looking a certain way that he doesn't
realize that we're his
his sons and that was kind of a wild
moment for me not to bring down the the
town you know I'm not trying to drown
the town here in uh in in her salt water
you know I'm not trying to you know put
the Saline in the in your eye holes but
but yeah just reminding me that that was
another thing that happened at Halloween
let me think of some other Halloween's
that I went to I they had this my mother
would had a station wagon and a station
wagon was something that it was like a
van but for straight-up real ass moms it
was like a SUV it was like the original
SUV like now they got these SUVs with
all this room and this and that the
station wagon that thing was like 50
feet long like your mom could be driving
and you could be so far in the back that
you were a couple minutes behind her in
time like if you to ask your mother what
time it was she would have said 11:44
and if somebody were to asked you what
time it was you just said 1141 because
you were living in the past that
backseat was so far and man it was fun
in that station wagon you know you could
talk all the smack does your mother
could never reach you these SUVs they
got reachable children in them you could
catch an ass-whooping if your mother got
long arms if your mother's Nigerian you
know if your mother's from Kenya you
might get you ass beat even if you're
just sitting into the back but would
that do with that with the station wagon
man you your mother could put you in
there you could be back there so long
you could start a family you know she
opened the door next time she opens the
door you pop out with a husband and uh
and a and a and a you know and just
freshly back outs Hann because you just
got back from your honeymoon it was that
kind of thing man you could feel like
you were back there forever in your own
universe and I loved my mother station
wagon but on Halloween she would put the
tailgate down and we get a couple of
local kids and uh and and they would we
would stand on the back of the tailgate
and hold on to this bar the tailgate was
down we'd stand on that and hold on this
bar that was at the top of the station
wagon and my mother would drive she take
us to the nice neighborhoods so you
could get that candy you know because
rich people had the candy
I mean you stood up at some poor
people's house people you know I
remember this one dude what was that
guy's name
cut me mister cut man he would uh blow
weed smoke in your face and blow drug
smoke at you and that was his big
Halloween thing so when we were young we
didn't get into that much but as we got
a little bit older it was fun to hit his
door because he cracked that door and
just blow you a hit of that uh that dope
smoke at you you know trick-or-treat boy
that [ __ ] was trick or try my do one
year that [ __ ] hit me right in the
nostrils dude and I was bent out you
know I was bent out well I was ghost and
dude I had Goonies in my head bro I had
Goonies in my head man but that was a
good time I remember and so anyway we'd
be we'd be we'd be on the station wagon
and that tailgate would be down my
mother would be cruising and the fun
thing to do when you saw that open yard
coming up was to run and jump off like
we were in the Air Force you know
hundred and first Airborne Division and
no offense if I'm getting that wrong I
don't want to offend anybody um or in
that sense but you get what I'm saying
we'd run and jump right off that
tailgating all right all right all right
all right you know throw my somebody
throw my sister off you know and
everybody just hitting the grass and
then everybody would get up and make
sure they had all their candy half the
candy roll out another end of the yard
but it was dark you didn't know you'd
get your bag and run to the door then
you'd hit a string of houses and then
get back on the tailgate and off around
to the next Street you know mother would
go around and we jump off you know so
this one boy man one time we're going
man and my buddy my buddy Danny and I've
talked about him before and he you know
very slender neck
I mean his neck if it was made out of
anything it was turkey bacon and so he
was long you know and long people
they're out there there's you're more
likely to catch a cold my dad always
told me you're more likely to catch a
cold when you're long because there's
more of you
you know if I'm only 20 inches tall
there's only 20 inches of me where a
cold can land I mean if I'm 27 inches
tall I'm a little longer than those
molecules are those you know those viral
antibodies or bodies that are floating
around they can land there's more room
for them to land
you know like I'm telling you it's
easier to land on Saturn than it is on
Pluto because there's more space that's
what I'm saying so my boy Danny was long
and he went running off and we were one
to were jumping off the tailgate hit in
the yard you know rolling over running
up and Danny goes running dude jumped
and hit literally landed right onto a
fire hydrant that was in somebody's yard
man
and I heard a sound come out of that boy
it didn't come out of his voice box it
didn't come out of it was almost like
his bone marrow just let out a [ __ ]
shriek like his bone marrow let out a
shriek and that's when I knew that night
time was dangerous man and that the
devil alert sometimes on Halloween he
was never the same he was never the same
before that but he was definitely he was
double never the same after he just
jumped sheer darkness and just caught
that fire hydrant just to the whole neck
and body you know and the crazy thing is
you could pop that hydrant open and run
water across him forever and he would
never get back to normal oh but it is
fall it is autumn and happy Halloween
you guys we're gonna be right back just
a second I got I got already Madison
studio I got in just a new way we're
gonna use him I got a plan
bear with me we got a few calls that
came in about the NFL we got a
got some pubic hair re configuration
something and we got a couple more
things we'll be right we'll be right
back just give me one second cuz
somebody just rang the doorbell I gotta
see who it is all right
but yeah it's that time of year it's the
time of year where things are fresh
October I think is a great month to
rattle off the things you want to get
done that have been plaguing you all
year set a few goals knock them out
before turkey time and before Christmas
because if you put your ear stick your
neck out a little now stick it out a
little bit further what are you here
I'll tell you what you [ __ ] here boy
and girl you hear a turkey with a jingle
bell around his neck and that's holidays
coming fast dude and if you don't think
the holidays are coming fast go outside
bend over and I tell you this for you
know what's going on you will have a
damn pilgrim with a [ __ ] sack full of
new toys hiding in your ass because
that's what I'm telling you the holidays
are coming quick and we got a great
episode for you guys man I'm excited I
didn't have that crazy of a weekend so
I'm just gonna kind of leave that right
there you know I spent some time I go to
therapy on Monday so I spend something
I'm ready to spend some time with my
therapist I'm trying to get you know
through tonight's episode so that I can
get some rest and be prepared sometimes
I go to this therapy session I'm not
prepared you know but I go to adult
therapy for males because I ain't no
wuss and if you're having problems if
you're having problems you feeling some
emasculation issues I want you to hit
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three I want you to hit
the hotline with some of the ways that
you're feeling as a man if you're having
a tough time being a man it could be in
any facet hit the hotline you don't even
need to leave your name if you don't
want to but just make you make sure your
story's real we've got some great calls
that came in
we got a we got a couple people calling
about taking a knee the NFL we got a
couple of amazing perspectives on that
we got we're talking about why we don't
have camels in America we're talking
about a follow up call from a gentleman
who you know we talked about it last
week about what would be the price be
that you would let your loved one get
out there and do sex with a stranger an
expensive stranger a stranger that's got
some money you know the rich how much
would you just let the rich just plow in
your loved one and we got a call that
came in about that we got some great
calls a man got hair transplants from a
place you probably wouldn't even expect
and you heard the doorbell a little bit
ago that's gonna be Ari Maness is gonna
be back here and and he's gonna be in
studio but the time when he's not in
here he's not in here this is our time
and this isn't is it isn't a time that I
share with him this is our time and the
time when I tell you he's not in here
he's not in here so I just want that to
be known a couple of other things before
we move on in the program I want to let
you know that I am headlining the
Hollywood improv October 10th at 8 p.m.
I got about we can do about 45 minutes
hot new material cool stuff you're gonna
love it
you can find those tickets on my website
Theo von comm as well I got the Hampton
ain't easy the tour shirts are available
now at Theo von com slash store and
those have all the tour dates on it from
this past year it's kind of a neat shirt
it's a few dollars price here because I
hit a couple extra colors put on it but
but it's a cool shirt man and I think
it's nice to have if you want to get
that you can go get it it's from it has
every city that I performed in this past
year and what else oh I got a new series
that's going to be that we're working on
a pilot for for Comedy Central so I'm
excited about that there's no money in
it yet but it's going to be a neat
opportunity and and it's all a little
bit based on this podcast so that's kind
of exciting but I just want to thank you
guys for being here with me today
happy Monday or whatever day it is this
week your your listening
and we're gonna be right back we're
gonna have already Madison studio I'm
gonna check on him briefly hit a couple
of news topics and then you and I are
gonna get back to some of your calls
I'll be right back this past weekend all
right and that is everything that you
need to know also if you want to support
the patreon you can go to
patreon.com/scishow and options on there
to donate thank you so much to our
patreon supporters I really appreciate
it allowing me to get a new camera and
eventually the goal is to come out with
a Thursday episode that better reflects
responses from Mondays Monday's episode
but with that said here's a couple of
thoughts he seems like a good dude the
one thing I would say no it's just maybe
having me a little bit funnier yes I
love your show
as far as Ari is concerned for someone
that you want to have with you all the
time
just pick someone that you enjoy being
around and someone who is professional
and someone who's professional be a
little bit funnier and someone who is
professional be a little bit funnier I
don't know why that did that you did
that I did that I would never do that
you did do that
you're lying not lying to me and you're
lying to all your fans there's a glitch
I think it was not a glitch okay fine
there wasn't a glitch man those are two
comments that just kind of there's a
couple calls that I got in you know and
I didn't you said we weren't gonna bring
up comments again you said we were just
gonna skip past that and just go into
the podcast you said we're not gonna
talk about it anymore
we weren't but then you just played it
yeah it's on the play sheet
yeah but you said to me before I said
hey are we gonna keep going over the
negative comments or we just yeah move
on you say oh yeah no we're past that we
are past it and then you just brought it
up again but I wanted to make sure
you're past it I was until you just
brought it up again now I'm back in it
now I'm back in I mean the funnier thing
fine you know comedy subjective
yes I didn't think I was funny some guy
well that guy yeah some people did some
people did
the professional thing mm-hmm first off
I feel like I'm professional
yeah and secondly you making that little
mixtape I was that's a mixed it you made
a nari hate mix okay that's my you're at
you my friend
Kevon made an re hate mixtape it's a hit
it's a remix of a couple of al okay a
remix you made re bass remix okay which
makes me think that you think I'm
unprofessional no you think I'm
unprofessional at all that's why I was
gonna actually if you do it he'll let me
gather my thoughts a little bit I was
gonna contradict what some of these guys
were saying I don't think you were
really no what do you think I was gonna
let you to drown out there and the dirty
water flattened me out here to John it's
okay I guess that's it I guess that's
what people want these days for
entertainment no I mean it look it's
very Rome it's very roam these days in
the podcast world you know they want to
see you get killed by a lion fight a
thousand squirrels you know there was
some man though if they didn't have a
line they would get thousands of
squirrels to fight man do you know that
I did not know that yeah
is that true yeah it's crazy you're not
pulling out of now and you think might
be true no not at all it's a real thing
all right cool
well here he is guys re man is right
here and what I want to say is what's
going on in ari's world I just want to
do a check-in with re so you know life's
good me and my girlfriend we made up
yeah last we check you guys have just
made love after the Grand Canyon yeah we
had gotten back together after Grand
Canyon things were a little shaky I
think we're on we're on good terms we
went to San Diego together
oh that's cool what was the occasion
weekend it was my younger brother
Jonah's birthday and I lined up some
shows as well so I was doing some comedy
and was going to visit my 17 year old 18
now oh wow and 18 and so we celebrated
by going to the whorehouse in Tijuana
Mexico really yeah they Hong Kong you
ever been there I've never been there
did you take Jonah
no Jonah stay behind even though he is
allowed to go as a teen in Mexico 18
you're a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh you're allowed to get murdered yes
seven or eight you're allowed to do
anything yeah but no this was just me my
girlfriend and one of my buddies another
Camille
it was on the show okay and yeah so we
went and I've been there four or five
times now I love the place you just go
there $80 you could just you know have
your way with a woman of your show how
and now do you feel any like emotional
repercussions from that you walk out of
there feeling like you know this isn't
good for me or this isn't good for my
psyche or something like that you just
feel you know honestly the first time I
walked out of there yeah I felt it was
cool it was like I can't believe this
place exists yeah because I mean
prostitution here exists but it's this
really Shady yes using a secret grimy
dangerous maybe yeah it's like you got a
like field hide in a recycling bin and
just wait just some kind of you know
yeah there's all right yeah they're not
called prostitutes are called escorts
there's all these rules yeah and they
they do a background check here it's
this legal establishment nice
establishment in fact when you walk in
what is it like is it like a CVS is it
like a it ready med is it like a 24-hour
Medical Center look what vibe is it it's
kind of just like the nicest strip club
I've ever been to I've only been to a
couple strip clubs okay in the US and is
it well-lit how's the lighting in there
it's lit kind of like a bar so it's not
super bright but it's not dark you could
definitely see around there's four
dollar beers there's three stories
there's jacuzzis or stripper poles
there's women there's people drinking
there's parties bachelor parties friends
hanging out at tables drinking beers and
so you walk in there and there's just
all these women it's lined up up and
down the place probably I'd say over a
hundred can you smell crotch in the air
when you walk in there honestly be
honest you north time you don't smell
crotch what you smell is cleaner cleaner
yeah products and it's I forget the name
of it but there's is it sent it in
anyway like orange cleaner products or
is it just basic cleaning I think
government type of clean I think a basic
Mexican government cleaning product
looks a little different than the clima
products here yeah it smells like
99-cent store
drama right so it smells like you did
lower end cleaning bro right maybe the
cleaning products aren't as good with
the people who were doing the cleaning
work harder yeah they were good it felt
it felt clean right and there yeah there
was no part of me while I was there that
was thinking this place is gross
because in America yeah you get a three
dollar Windex or shine X or whatever
three bucks but the person doing the
works putting in a dollars worth of
effort that's right but John in Mexico
you get a dollar for a product yeah you
get three dollars worth the effort I
think that's I never thought about that
and you're spot-on with that so you go
in there and you do it I've been there
three or four times now were you nervous
when you walk in because I would be
extremely nervous in there I was only
nervous this time cuz I'm with my
girlfriend okay and she says she's cool
with it she's like I don't care there's
they're just prostitutes you're not
cheating on me if we go here she even
she was thinking she would get into it
she goes I'd be down to watch you have
sex with a prostitute Wow I think that
could be you know kind of hot and fine
yeah so we go very um very Lake of the
Ozarks Missouri that's swinger country
if you never spend time yeah oh yeah
there's a good I wandered into a
swingers weekend up there one time on
accident yeah I did you uh partake
no I couldn't do anything I could watch
the bingo that they played and then I
wasn't supposed to get in the elevator
for like 11:00 to 1:00 a.m. because it
was basically just like a [ __ ] trolley
just going up and down the building but
but I did press the button one time and
the doors open and there was just a
brother in there just putting down the
hammer and some older white women but
anyway go on so we go in there she's
drinking a little bit more than me okay
I get sauced up which made me think
she's uncomfortable that yeah and that
made me a little uncomfortable
and I kind of just got this vibe that
she was just pretending to be into this
whole experience your girlfriend to be
cool yeah to be the cool girlfriend of
course that is letting me have sex with
a prostitute so I didn't end up doing it
yeah I ended up not partaking did it
feel like a gang like is at that point
when you say that the cool girlfriend
that's letting me have sex with a
prostitute that makes me thing like gang
like somebody that's in a gang like no
like she's in a gang no like you like
you this is all some type of
type of that seems like something that
happens in gangs you know like I'm gonna
bang your friend you know you stay here
you have this snack or something and I'm
gonna bang your friend you know like
sounds like you know more about gangs
than I do I there's like initiation type
stuff and the girls probably play along
with stuff to seem cool and comfortable
you know yeah it just felt like maybe
because we are on weird turns from our
last fight Minchin wanted to be like who
takes a girlfriend to the Greg gets in a
fight at the Grand Canyon and to make up
for it takes him down to a hooker house
in Tijuana yeah it was just one of those
things we I've talked about hookers on
stage sometimes she's know she knows I
had been there I'm open about my life
and did anybody there know you when you
got there no but I did actually see one
of the prostitutes
I had expire experience with but she did
not remember me at all or he'll he
noticed me Andy your girlfriend did you
tell your girlfriend you been with that
woman I did Wow I got that one last time
and she was like oh cool and so and I
don't think that bothered her I were
fine from from this whole experience
nothing affected our relationship from
this I think mainly though because I was
keen enough yeah and I picked up on the
fact that she didn't really want me to
do it and she didn't really want to see
that and I felt that so because I'm a
gentleman and because I care about her I
decided hey I don't want it I said I
don't really want to do this I said
you're prettier than all these girls
you're much more beautiful it is true
she then all those girls yeah it's
pretty lady and I said we don't need to
do this we got some delicious street
tacos right outside a Mexican taco truck
there and right outside yeah right
outside the whorehouse there's this taco
truck got a whole plate of tacos for
four bucks together together we picked
out it was delicious
Wow and we got back to my parents house
4 a.m. crashed out on the air mattress
woke up drove back here unbelievable
dude yeah it's almost like a modern-day
Romeo and Juliet you know yeah except
better interesting Ari manis well I
appreciate that check-in man appreciate
letting us know what's going on yeah why
don't you lead us into a couple of news
category right first category speaking
of
you know sex semen contaminated flutes
might have been given to children so the
California school officials warned that
several school districts in Southern
California there were a flute donation
musical and donation from this this man
I guess could start an organization
called flutes across the world and now
they think that the flutes he donated in
he also jerked off onto and then give
them to kids Wow mmm I mean that's uh
how are they gonna know it said in the
story they don't know how this came how
they found out but someone found out but
there's semen everywhere like it's like
when you walk into a motel or a hotel or
an abandoned building you know when you
find a stray dog you know like you could
go look on the YouTuber and there's
people out there spending way inaccurate
time with animals you know it's like
there's semen on everything we're made
out of semen when you think about it
we're from it everybody wants to walk
around and act like you know it's this
taboo product you know like it's
something that people are you know
secretly busing in from China or
something or from Korea
we're semen you are semen dude I agree
with what you're saying 100% so a little
on a flute but some kid who's even more
recently of seed than us
I just who are they gonna say did it I'm
sure they'll probably say Trump didn't
know anything the guy who donated the
flutes mm-hmm did it but was also doing
see well you know what doesn't surprise
me a guy that has a bunch of flutes yeah
seems like a guy that probably is
jerking off on the stuff first of all if
you know anybody that has more than one
flute I'd phone them in right now bro
and the number to call for that is nine
one one you get what you pay for they
took these free flutes yeah they're free
flutes yeah I can't be complaining about
if you don't want semen on your flutes
then buy brand-new flew yeah on Amazon
but if you're gonna take these donated
flutes yeah you get what you pay for
yeah that's the thing you want a handful
of free marbles dude they smell like the
inside of my ass you know what that's
life dude and that's gay
it's playing for us right now all right
newsman speaking of that that's the news
let's get into one call right here while
we got our a Madison studio here we go
and and the number is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three you
can always hit the hotline with any
thoughts comments concerns or questions
let's tap into this right here what a
dude the name's Jeff toy Jeff too we
Asian capital we you're thinking at Jo
koy from Kentucky Louisville Kentucky I
just wanted to let us know that I too
had a hair removal procedure mmm this is
in response to the hair transplant that
I got almost 14 days ago I kid you not
man but it wasn't on my dome it was on
my face so you know I have a hard time
growing a beard I got that engine in me
and that means Native American I don't
think he's talking about Hemi but he and
I know what he's talking about actually
there's a there's part of my throat it's
almost like a choke mark where I swear
my mother choked me when I was young
that will not grow hair yeah I can't
grow a full beard yeah so it yeah that
thing is way shoddy dude okay well no
that's actually just ringing me down a
bad dude you know it doesn't look that
bad it looks like scruff some chicks
like that yeah it looks like like you've
been kind of living in New York but
outdoors yeah in my family and so I
can't grow I can't grow a lot of facial
hair okay guy well let's get to it so
you know if you grow like a 10 beard or
a neck beard you know the hair is
they're a little greasy chin beard and
neck beard look a lot like peas they do
and so I'm actually going through the
procedure right now getting some pubes
so I got plenty of those transport it to
my face
a little worried though now I asked for
your prayer requests it's one let you
know let you know that you're not alone
in this and God bless you
Wow he took it to the Lord at the end
and I've been at Halloween before where
we you know we needed beards and stuff
and we would cut off pubes and each
other's pubes because some people had
better stock and use that to make our
beards and mustaches for Halloween you
know outfits what do you think about
this guy what do you think about this re
about getting that transplant if this is
real to me that sounds like a prank
phone call really but I thought about it
I don't think it does you say you things
real so if he's really getting his pubes
to his neck he's transplanting his pubes
and moving them to his neck I think
there's a bigger issue why is he so
insecure about not being able to grow a
beer right shave your face just don't be
a beard guy just be a shaven man I mean
it's just an old prison trick like in
prison a lot of times if you read a lot
of these old like prison Diaries and
stuff and you can get a lot of these on
the Deep Web which is just like they've
they've digitized prison Diaries and you
can read about the things they did at
Halloween and a lot of the things they
did was use different types of body
stuff that they had even dandruff that
they would collect all year to make
different types of costumes and stuff
like that you know so it's pretty
interesting to hear you know like a guy
would be like you know Tony Montana but
it would be like you know four or five
six people's dandruff that he would use
to make the cocaine stream coming out of
his face you know it's almost it's
almost spookier that way you know when
you leave the house with four people's
dandruff glued to your cheek yeah you
know and your cousin and a pubic
mustache made out of here could that
your cousin grew for you you know that's
Rochester New York right there be a
little bit funnier oh this is broken
this is no it's not broken be a little
bit funnier yeah all right yeah I guess
I forgive you thanks for having me on
you bet re- ladies and gentlemen and
I'll be right back into second with
we're gonna get into the rest of these
calls we got some great ones this past
weekend ok and we are back with our a
manís is out of here you know I think
we're just going to continue to try this
for another week at least see how it
fits with re I liked him
you know I like checking in with his
life to see what's going on and I like I
like having a couple of news segments
that I don't have to think about and
prepare so it can be kind of fresh to me
but let's let's get into some of your
calls we had a lot of great calls about
the NFL and a lot of great calls about
the sitting taking a knee the the
national anthem issues and and I thought
a little bit more about it over this
past week and I think everybody did
because it's something that's you know
that's in the air you know and certainly
in the past few years I found myself
thinking a lot more like what are my
like thoughts innately
and feelings innately towards people
that are different than me you know
where do I stand what do I think what do
I feel I found myself doing that more
and I think that that's great
awareness is awareness is eventually key
in every aspect your life but what I'm
also noticing is and hearing about that
the taken knee thing was very vague it
was like okay well we're upset at at
racial injustice then we're upset at
Trump and then were like it's a police
brutality it was like well what's it for
you know I understand it's for different
things but it was just this is the first
year that I really felt like it was you
know it just seemed because if you if
you it almost started to make it so that
the awareness stuff is starting to lose
some of its effect that's what I felt
like because every week
and everyday if you keep saying oh this
is about awareness this batch of
cupcakes is about black lives matter
this this this casserole is for daca
repeal this if every it just it gets to
be overwhelming so that nothing is for
anything because if you're saying that
everything is something then nothing is
for anything you know it's like it just
wears it out and I think people are
starting to get won't worn out and I've
noticed from different friends of mine
that that they're just there seems to be
this vibe that people are just tired of
hearing constantly about blame you know
if you want to blame white people for
ever about the issues of the world then
you can start in Britain you know is the
civilization humanities civilization
apparently began in Africa and Egypt I
think so if you want to go all the way
back to there keep on going we can keep
cruising through the history books and
you want to blame it on two organisms in
a desert that got hit by lightning or
you want to blame it on two monkeys that
met in the woods or you want to blame it
on Adam and Eve I mean at a certain
point you're just gonna keep like at a
certain point we just have to look at
where we are and we have to look at what
role we are also currently playing in
our own problems because that's some of
the issue that I start to have
personally is yeah I know that there's I
know that there's issues in America
where there are racial and Justices I
know that some people are don't have as
good of opportunities as other people I
know those things I think that most
people want to fix them but and and are
happy to find ways to do that but if
someone just constantly just yells
everything is wrong everything is wrong
at a certain point they're not helping I
don't feel like they're not helping to
be part of the solution so I guess I'm
just trying to be a little bit more
solution oriented you know and also what
do you play in your own problems you
know like yes there's tons of problems
in black community but there's also some
of those problems are problems that the
black communities help solve for the
needs to at least work together with
other people to solve for themselves you
know like not everything is white
people's fault you know if you are and
you know and I hate to use black and
white just is the only example but
that's just like the biggest example
that's going on right now you know but I
just hate to see activism get diluted by
being overused and maybe that's naive of
me to think that that's not even
possible
and I'm open if that's if that's the
case then I'm open to be corrected there
but I just hate to see it's not like the
boy who cried wolf is just like the wolf
keeps crying boy it's like the wolf just
says boy boy boy boy boy boy boy you
know and there's no there's never any
real communication between the boy and
the wolf it's just the wolf keeps
yelling boy and at a certain point it's
like you can't hear the wolf yelling boy
anymore because they just won't stop
yelling it and you think that the wolf
may have autism and that's how we came
back full circle on autism and people
say well Theo you can't talk about
autism guess what if I show up on the
spectrum then I can and if you want to
put me to a test I'll take any day of
the week dude you can blindfold me and
put both my hands under a under a baby's
ass and put a number-two pencil in my
mouth and I'll [ __ ] take that test on
my tongue and you'd be like well I don't
know if you have autism what only an
autistic person could do that so check
yourself let's get some of your thoughts
and feelings right here here we go
on the NFL techinique uh you were
talking about taking a knee for the
anthem during football games now I don't
really see what taking a knee during a
football game has anything to do with
police brutality so I don't really see
the connection of the protest
however as far as what my opinion is on
them actually taking a knee I think as a
country shouldn't demand patriotism from
people oh it's interesting interesting
thought like yeah patriotism you can't
demand that out of somebody that they
care about America that's that's true to
me that feels unfortunate that they
don't but but it feels true that we
shouldn't be able to demand it onward
demanding patriotism from people is the
sort of thing that the Nazis and the
Soviets used to do now some feel the
general dissatisfaction with their
nation and doesn't think that their
nation deserves patriotism from them
then I kind of support their right to do
that however at the same time I kind of
think the whole healing for the an
something doesn't really send the
message of a protest against police
brutality hey and I love the podcast
yeah it just seemed a little vague it
seemed a little vague as to what was
going on and what was happening but yeah
you can't demand patriotism I mean he's
right that's very that's how a lot of
you know Avilla T gets started in the
world you would hope that people have it
but I guess we're just in such a diverse
and different and a time now where
people some people have it and some
people don't maybe America is such a
melting pot now where a lot of places
you don't see that much patriotism you
know I mean I'll be honest here in Los
Angeles I don't see it very much
I can go seek it out you know on
Veterans Day I can go to the cemetery or
on the 4th of July I can go to an event
but otherwise you don't you don't see a
lot of American flags here in Los
Angeles you know I think maybe some
places are just so diverse where some
people it's not they don't care about
America first even I mean I think some
people do but there's also a vibe in
some places where they don't you know
and that's okay
you know some people look at America
almost as like a an airport it seems
like for the rest of the world where you
can come here and you can live here and
you can shop here and you can get a
hotel here and stay here and then you
can go back on to wherever you know you
care about more you know that's I think
that's a vibe in some places but I think
you just have to find a place then that
reflects a little bit more of your of
what you desire because then you can
live in a reality that is a little more
comfortable for you I think it's you
still should recognize that there are
these other realities out there though
but I don't think there's anything wrong
with living in one where you think
you're best suited for all right let's
go on to another call here weird stuff
down here okay Logan thank you for
calling doing some weird stuff down here
I don't know what that is but I
appreciate you checking in with us
onward I thought I might try a different
angle see what you had to say so a lot
of times people want to seems America's
mostly about convenience
about convenience he's saying go ahead
so like you don't see people standing up
at the bar oh and the when the national
anthem comes on you don't see people
standing up at home when the national
anthem comes on I'm not necessarily
going to comment on the exact needling
asides for him I don't really disagree
with it I'm kind of in the neutral zone
can't really do much harm it's up to the
owners I mean up to the owners and the
advertisers it's not my not my fight
they're using their field
okay so he's saying that these players
are you know they if their owners are
allowing them the team owners are
allowing them to do that then you know
and that's where they want to use their
stance to show uniformity and take a
knee then that's where they can do it
you
that's that it's up to the owners and in
the end that's really true I think if
the lot of those owners started saying
you're not going to get a paycheck you
know I wonder how those people would
adjust you know because there's a lot of
people in Los Angeles who you know we're
probably afraid to say that they were
Trump supporters or we're voting for
Trump because afraid they would lose
their jobs you know or in most of
America and air in different places and
vice versa I'm sure there were a lot of
people you know in in other places that
were afraid to say that they were
Hillary supporters or they would lose
their jobs you know and that's
unfortunate I think that we're at a
point where people you know don't want
to or can't be that we can't even be
open to other people's perspectives and
ideas you know I think if it's a
dangerous perspective our idea we can
totally not accept it but I think you
still have to find ways to be able to
hear it and to be open to it you know
because you might learn you might change
your mind you know and change I think is
always good even if you just change your
mind a little bit and take a little
piece of what they know or their
perspective you know I mean I'm grateful
right here because I'm thinking about
some different perspectives - you guys
are calling in with them but that's true
he's also saying like how big of an it
like people at bars aren't standing up
and doing the Pledge of Allegiance you
know could you imagine that if everybody
in a bar now in some countries they may
you know I feel like if you get to some
of these other countries you're at an
Irish bar or something and it's a soccer
game that they might really get down and
put that hand on the chest but I don't I
don't think that they're doing that here
in America you know it's so it's but
then it's that's part of the being at
the game it's like when you're at the
event that's where people do it but I'm
also thinking like I'm feeling that even
after a week or so of this going on that
people are starting to lose they almost
just don't care what these players do
you know and not because they're black
or not because they're white or because
they're Latino at the end there's only a
few Asian players I believe but just
because they're just it's getting hack
it's getting old it's getting old
without us having more of a direction
for solution and I think that it's
getting old just pointing fingers and
not pointing the finger also at oneself
to figure out how can we better better
you know how can we better achieve the
successes that we want in America
all right let's just grab another call
on take a knee here we go hey Brandt I
appreciate you callin brother Tacoma now
that is outside of Seattle probably
about maybe it's 15 miles and that is a
little bit of cowboy country and if you
like pine trees and evergreens
and-and-and Cowboys at the same time you
can get that in Tacoma now sometime
people think of Seattle that's fish
country you know a nest up there people
you know Brett and they got men even
breastfeeding children and people
shaving their chest hair and making
wallets out of them and all that kind of
stuff you know a bunch of dreamcatcher
addicts and people you know eating
homemade cinnamon made out of their own
you know skin flakes and um and and and
flavors out of nature but but if you get
outside of Seattle not even far Tacoma
is a little more cowboy country so they
might have fish out there but they call
it water cattle that's what they call
fish over there in Tacoma they call it
water cattle because that's uh that's
the livestock of of that salty h2o all
right
another issue where the media's have
having another tool to exploit the
vision in America I think there's a lot
of that going on right now
you can see it in the local news you'll
get some polls of people that are going
to boycott teams and half of them are
saying they're going to boycott the
season
g-man a say they aren't and that's a
good point like the media doesn't even
if you notice with these polls now it's
half and half a lot of the polls oh it's
always half and half really that's
striking because if they can keep it
half in half then they can keep it they
can make it seem divided and that's just
interesting man it used to be a poll was
a real poll you know and not since the
election I have I trusted any polls I
don't care who the poll is from because
the problem is the people taking the
polls and the people running the polling
companies the friends or the whoever
they're even polling they don't even
there those people are just like people
you know a buddy of mine runs a network
here in Los Angeles and he's telling me
that you know well the first thing we do
when we want to see if a show is good we
take it downstairs and we ask everybody
who works in our company yeah but 98% of
the people working your company have
gone through the same schools or you
know friends a friend of who already in
the company got them the job it's just
it's like just asking the same person
you know that's why I feel like taking
polls where you don't have an accurate
group to take them from just doesn't end
well but yeah it's kind of fascinating
that the polls are always 50/50 now and
that that behooves the media the most
because it keeps people arguing and
that's not every case I understand that
onward what you're seeing with
bipartisan affiliation and what we're
going there yeah the Charlottesville
issue and just a lot of division in in
America right now in the US and the
media is highlighting it you know the
media is supposed to be a tool that
helps inform us but it certainly changed
into something different where it's
entertainment and it's rolling people
and it's giving us all false impressions
and what's actually going on that's true
it's a good point you know and I feel
most bad I appreciate you
Collin and these are some good points
and I feel most I feel most bad and
that's not the right term but I can't
think of it right now I feel most bad
for seniors who you know we were older
who were in hospice who are you know
maybe there are spouses passed away left
for heaven or wherever and they've
always thought that the world was a good
you know good enough place and they
thought that maybe they're leaving the
world better for their children or that
they you know they raised their kids
right their whole life or did the best
they could will say that and then now
here you have and they don't realize
that the news is turned into this that
the media is turned into this element
that's not reliable that's not just
sharing information and that's sad you
know that's said because they think that
then you know I bet that causes a lot of
depression in them you know a lot of new
senior depression because suddenly the
world that they thought was a better
place that they were leaving behind it
probably isn't as bad but it looks that
bad and they don't know the difference
maybe because of senility because
they're not as in touch with the vibe
these days they don't realize it you
know some of what the media is doing is
not healthy but I agree the polls are 50
feels keep on 50-50 that way things are
dividing you know when I do I think that
we are better than the media makes us
out to be then the news makes us out to
be I really do and I think that these
are good times you know I mentioned this
couple weeks ago I had lunch with Howie
Mandel of a month or so ago and you know
he's been a friend of me for a few years
now and he said this is right when the
Charlottesville stuff happened and he
said you know I'm happy that this kind
of thing is happening and how he's
Jewish I think at least half Jewish can
if you can even just be half but he said
I'm glad this kind of stuff is happening
because now at least you know who people
are you know before you don't you know
maybe you didn't know where the guy
across the street stood you know what
his thoughts were what his real feelings
were you know but at least now there's
oh there's at least a vibe where you do
know
you know some people are coming feelings
that have been hidden under people's
brains are coming to the surface and
making people think and making people
act you know but I appreciate that call
let's keep it cruising here here we go
hey CEO Tom out to you NFL players
kneeling now I'm coming from a place of
a wife privilege I'm a white dude so
obviously I had white privilege growing
up my dad was uh he was a tenth of ten
children who ten out of ten dang boy
that's that post makers dozen boy ten
children onward post makers post post
man's dozen onward lived in a
two-bedroom house on a clay road in
Alabama
well y'all gotta get asphalt man if you
don't have any asphalt hit up some
gypsies if you got any gypsy friends
that live out there in the Midwest or
whatever they'll sell you some bad to
probably decent asphalt on word I was
born he were to make a minimum wage he
was supporting my mom and two other kids
suffer from depression anxiety he died
in his early 60s from drinking and
drugging but you know what my wife
privilege was is when my dad told me son
I don't care if you grew up to be a
ditch digger if you do grow up to be a
ditch to you'd be the best damn ditch
digger there is and that's that's my
privilege my dad told me to work hard
what I'm afraid is happening with these
NFL players you got the young
impressionable kids looking up to these
guys they're kneeling on the field and
the message they're taking home you can
I see these kids are taking home is
someone that I can give me I can't do it
why even try there's a whole system
against me why should I even try
appreciate your call that's an
interesting take you know if you're a
child at home if you're a black child
maybe even if you're a you know a mixed
child you know I don't know I mean I'm
not these children you know I don't have
these children
but could that affect the way if you see
you know even your hero's saying that
they don't have that maybe your race
doesn't have a chance or if you catch
that vibe from some of this could that
be negative for them could that make
them not want to work as hard it could
be you know it could be I appreciate
your call and I appreciate that thought
let's move on to another one
and look I'm just I'm happy to have you
guys as calls and thoughts here man and
you know this is a big topic that a lot
of people had thoughts on here we go hey
Theo my name is Shea from Indiana
thank you for calling Shea Indiana and
actually I just got a call recently said
that Indiana was not the home of the Ku
Klux Klan that it was actually somewhere
in Tennessee some have to look that up
wherever it was bummer
onward I served 12 years in the Army
infantry and thank you for your service
onward
I understand protesting and I'm not I'm
not unaware of the strife that
african-americans go through with police
officers in certain areas and I agree
there needs to be something done police
officers need to be vetted better
trained better you know sometimes
they're just putting crazy people on the
streets of the gun yeah that's true man
you know sometimes they are sometimes
they aren't you know you wish that these
guys got paid more
you know you wish that teachers and and
police officers and public service those
people got paid more you know you also
have you know decades of police going
into neighborhoods that are extremely
scary going in extreme high crime areas
so probably a lot of you know PTSD from
past experiences I can't even imagine in
addition to racist cops you know in
addition to the fact that racism exists
and uh yeah I mean there's a lot of
thoughts on it onward for me when I see
people kneeling at the anthem like that
you got to think about why we do the
national anthem to begin with unknown
ceremony no we're doing it
you know to understand where you come
from and the liberties and the freedoms
you have because people did die
they lost Williams they lost lives they
sacrificed their minds so you can live
in a place like this mmm that's a
powerful line they sacrifice their mind
it's a good line onward we need a fixed
thing you need to be fixed but if you're
going to use your platform use it for
good use of positivity and lipstick
there's something else and let's make
people aware doing a senseless act by
just nailing it just causes the vision
and hate but uh that's my high horse is
my stand thank you thank you appreciate
it
yeah Maisie what yeah I mean are we
helping is this helping are we finding
solution because here's I don't think
the media doesn't care if we find
solution you know if we solve the
problems in the world let me tell you
who doesn't benefit probably the news
networks can you imagine if the world
were good and comfortable would we even
turn the news on if we knew that
everyone was doing okay you know it
makes you start to ask yourself why do I
even watch news am i addicted to the
hatred am i addicted to the you know to
the negativity am i supporting it by the
things I watch and the things that I you
know click on I don't know I don't I do
not know all right let's hear a little
bit more let's take another call right
here hey man um why we don't have camels
here in North America seems like they
can live in the rest of the regular
world and sand and I you know hot Sun
and the Sun burned the sand on their
feet and they can get all that water in
them then they would do a lot better he
dang bro I appreciate the call yeah why
we don't have camels
why we don't have camels here in America
that's a great question
you know it is because you know you go
to some of these other countries and
they have camels you go to India oh
you'll see a camel look out in the woods
you'll see it you'll see a distinct
you'll see a distant camel you go to
where else you go to Africa oh you
oh they got camels out there if you got
a hat made out of um reeds
made out of uh you know read um pieces
of of greenery a camel will eat your hat
first thing you stand in there and you
got a little bit of shade on your head
next thing you know the Sun is hitting
you and you hear something chewing
nearby and that's a camel just a chore
hat so they have camels out there but in
America you know you get around here and
it's not like that you know and I think
part of it is because we're not as
natural I mean dude you go to Africa you
get a rental car they might have a
[ __ ] sloth in the trunk you know you
go to um Nairobi and you get a pair of
pants and you put them on and they might
have a uh a couple of um they might have
a you know a lizard or something in the
crotch of them an exotic lizard
so you get a lot of these different
countries you're gonna see some animals
in America you might just get a couple
of pesky raccoons out there you know
throwing dice and [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
you know and just [ __ ] around in the
garbage making love about a garbage you
know we don't get like we don't get as
many wild animals now you get up into
different parts out there to Montana you
know you might get some Tigers you know
if you get a you might get some mountain
cats even some aggressive lesbians if
you hanging out by the gas station at
night because I got accosted by a
lesbian out there one time it could I
think it was pretty much a lesbian
aggressive lesbians now
I'm not saying anything about all
lesbian this was an aggressive an
aggressive lesbian had a Dakin t-shirt
on this old band Dokken but they have
you know we don't have that natural
wouldn't have this camels running around
and I don't know why I do not know why
at all but that's a great question man
why we don't have camels in the United
States of America let's get them talk to
trump dude Trump will get you some
[ __ ] camels bro all right let's hit
another question here oh and this
question had to do with last week it was
if your girlfriend wanted to sleep with
somebody else if you got that offer
because someone on snapchat last week
called in with the offer they got let's
hear this yo what's up baby calling from
mama keep my name out and I call I'm
calling from Toronto Canadia Toronto
almost made love to an Indian woman up
there one time or pretty much a woman of
age but just outside of that and I went
to Halloween I celebrated Halloween up
there one time with the ShamWow guy my
buddy Vince offer he went to a party and
he ended up meeting a white girl that I
think he ended up making love too long
word Canada I just wanted to talk about
last week if you've let somebody else
sleep with your girl or vice versa maybe
your girls letting you sleep with other
chicks whatever yep you can find that on
our 925 episode homeward I don't know
what if I've practiced the dark arts as
you put it you put the dark arts I'm a
proponent of the dark arts I might be an
elder I don't know okay see you out
there man you Edgar Allen go boy
homework yeah me and my girlfriend you
know it started off totally healthy as
most relationships do everything's fun
everything's new and exciting whatever
and as time went you know you learned
something about your girl she's a freak
my girl was a freak she's crazy she was
into crazy [ __ ] and so was I and you
kind of awakened the dark arts in each
other so okay now you want to do
threesomes and then it turns to well why
don't we just have an open relationship
okay so now you open relationship
that's when anybody can come through and
shoot your dough you know let's open
season that's hunting season and that's
when you sharing your crops with the
neighbors and that's when it can get a
little ornery when you look across that
fence and see somebody else eating your
vegetables onward mmm okay so now we're
shaking our heads like oh is this is
this normal like can we do this how do
we do this and it practically ruined our
relationship in the end of it I was
letting her oh man I was almost hopeful
for a second that you figured this out
that you had this let's keep going sleep
with other dudes she got jealous and
didn't want me to sleep with other girls
and then eventually because of something
some deep-seated weird dark art that I
had in a part of me I started to like
that she was sleeping with other guys
and she would film it and she we would
watch it and it was like a part of our
relationship but wow wow boy that's
crazy man I mean you're in there then
you know if you have you watching videos
of other men which are lady you know
that's very I want to say Roman but
that's even passed that you passed Roman
Wow let's hear more man that's not
healthy and I knew that but I just
couldn't help it you know things
progress you just get bored with the
regular [ __ ] so I don't know it kind of
ruined our relationship I think in the
end she won't admit to it but I think
that's what it was
well yeah let me know what you think
about that oh man I think I mean look
I'd be lying if I didn't say some of it
sounded fun you know if it doesn't sound
fun to be just you know crawling down
that dirty staircase on your hands and
knees you know and you know that each
step below you and you're going
face-first down that staircase because
when you get naughty like that you
face-first you know as a man you going
face-first you've taken all your
feelings in your you know all your
senses your senses are all in your head
and in your fingertips so you're taking
all those face-first down the stairs
into the darkness and you know that the
devil built that next step you know each
step built by you know carpenter
Satan or carpenter Lucifer you know you
know that each one of them steps getting
warmer and naughty or slippery but you
keep going hand first on your knees down
that staircase and your nostrils and
your brain filling up with sense filling
up with the scent of musky women you
know in Best Westerns and you know in uh
in private account credit cards you know
and cheap things of cocaine and uh you
know and people wearing [ __ ] little
outfits on their dick and all kinds of
stuff like that and you getting into
some wildness man but you keep going
because that's the temptation that's
temptation man that's what that is
and look I feel you that can be fun but
that doesn't end well that's the thing
that doesn't end well or we would all
probably be there so now here you are
you know you're a little bit burnt out
you sound like you got some issues from
it but I'll just say keep climbing man
turn around keep walking up I must say
you and I've to always be good am i
saying any of that
I'm not saying God's gonna say you am I
saying any of that all I'm saying is
that it doesn't sound like the safest
environment and that's why the struggle
is where it is that's why the struggle
is just stay in the healthy relationship
or even if it's a you know to try and
make a relationship healthy that's why
we're battling it out which is spouse
that's why cuz you fighting that front
lines you ain't out there eating
buttholes off the Internet's you know of
random strangers off the Internet's with
a buttholes you're not doing all of that
you know and that's hard it's hard not
to do it's hard not to do all right
let's keep it cruising
yeah I feel hey I I just got done
watching the 925 episode
thank you for checking that out as far
as the kneeling that's the national
anthem it just needs to stop
entertainers have opinions
football players need to play football
the NFL needs to play football and stay
out of the political realm Trump means
to shut his mouth and become a real
president and stop talking a bunch of
[ __ ] to people to get him stirred up
it's not helping anyone move forward I
agree I mean just as much as the media
does it Trump does it as well I mean
it's just it's almost baffling where
that comes from for him I mean it's just
like a baby you know it's like watching
a tall baby with with Twitter on word so
this needs to quit needs to end people
need to come together and [ __ ] stand
up the dance them and move on you know
we play football that's what that's
about entertainment so I just wanted to
pass that along and I appreciate that
what else ma'am I got some more stuff
about girls and dating we're gonna get
into that next week I feel like we've
already been into a really long episode
so far we got a bunch of great calls and
more of them will be on next week I'm
probably gonna get into some stuff about
dating I've been dealing with some stuff
in this therapy I've been going to I've
been dealing with some stuff about my
issues lie when I'm unable to connect in
a relationship you know I even get
caught up when I got intimate intimate
issues you know when it comes to being
in love and getting you know a
comfortable consistent level of intimacy
that stuff whoo that's hard it's hard
for me it's hard for a lot of people did
I'm telling you this I'm sitting in a
doctor's office the other day and I'm
talking about something something that's
okay and I mentioned this you know just
in passing just about I was going to a
therapist and out of the blue this man
closed the door and then he started
telling me the problems he was having at
home and this is a doctor this is a
doctor talking to me about the problems
he been having you know issues he having
in his bedroom and so man it's just they
got people's out there dealing with that
people out there dealing we afflicted
man we're all afflicted and that's okay
we've all got a problem man you know but
we you gonna be out there hiding it you
know you can be out there the same with
the problem is and what how you do you
think we can solve it
because you could wear the disguise if
you want you could put on the disguise
everything's fine you know everything's
fine everything's fine that's the
disguise man that's here Halloween bro
that's your Michael Myers outfit you
wear every day or you could take off the
mask man inhale you know you could take
off your mask and see if daddy
recognizes you you know you could take
off that mask and show up show up with
no no masks on no outfit no costume show
up to whomever to your boss to your
spouse and let them know what's going on
let them know what's poppin off inside
of you you know be vulnerable sometime
you got to show up and be vulnerable man
so and that's a tough thing to do it's a
tough thing for men to do you know and
it's a tough thing I think for ladies
too ladies getting confused ladies used
to be our Maps you know I think at times
for vulnerability we would watch them
who would Marvel and who they were and
now sometimes we've been led in
directions where we don't know you know
we don't know where we stand we don't a
who's-who anymore it's a little bit
confusing that's okay we just got to
keep navigating you know so if you Lewis
find you're Clark you know get you a
Clark can be a buddy give me a loved one
you know get vulnerable with a friend
man share we just [ __ ] out here dude
we out here we got here in space on
any shame man you want shame you keep
shame
I'm not holding on to that [ __ ] anymore
I appreciate you guys calling man I'm
gonna take us out right here this is
Spencer Jacob growl band with a song
that I love from them and celebrate
living
[Music]
celebrate
the flame is
[Music]
thank you guys very much man you guys be
good to yourselves
we all die
celebrate